on va débattre du droit d'asile on
accueille Valérie Boyer Valérie Boyer
merci beaucoup de nous rejoindre en
direct sur ce plateau je vous en prie
installez vous vous êtes sénatrice les
républicains des Bouches-du-Rhône merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous face à l'œil
signor je le rappelle paroles de
renaissance et donc on va débattre de ce
sujet du droit d'asile faut-il le
réformer la question et dans le débat
politique depuis l'attaque de Nancy
jeudi est-ce que cette attaque de Nancy
Loïc signore pour vous elle pose la
question de la réforme du droit d'asile
et la question du droit d'asile elle est
posée depuis un certain temps à
Bruxelles en Union Européenne ou les
ministres de l'Intérieur l'échelle des
têtes gouvernement les parlementaires
consultent et vote même sur des
dispositions c'est le cas du pacte
d'Asie l'immigration qui a été votée par
les parlementaires européens il y a
quelques semaines les ministres de
l'Intérieur et Gérald Darmanin
d'ailleurs le jour de l'attaque était à
Bruxelles pour en parler avec ses pairs
et un accord a été trouvé le droit
d'asile nous nous sommes vous attacher à
la Convention de Genève et on pense
qu'on doit absolument respecter le
fondement ensuite est-ce qu'il faut dans
la granularité des dispositifs faire des
modifications oui sans doute la manière
dont on accueille les gens dans nos pays
la manière dont on doit répartir les
personnes qui arrivent sur le continent
européen et la manière aussi peut-être
dont il doivent se déplacer et c'est à
l'aune de ce que nous avons vu à Annecy
que nous découvrons qu'il y a peut-être
effectivement certaines failles dans le
dispositif mais à aucun moment il ne
faut remettre en cause nos acquis de
1951 la Convention de Genève et le droit
d'asile qui est un fondement absolu de
nos démocraties je le crois et il ne
faudrait absolument pas changer ces
dispositifs même s'il faut sans doute
revoir et encore une fois on est à
disposition de chacun pour en discuter
des mécanismes dans lesquels il peut se
trouver des failles
d'abord avec vous Alexa quelles sont
aujourd'hui les chiffres du droit
d'asile effectivement alors dans les 27
pays de l'Union européenne en 2022 il y
a eu 962 000 demandes qui représente une
hausse de 52% par rapport à 2021 et
parmi ces demandes d'asile 310 000 ont
été acceptés et puis en France en 2022
on dénombre 156.000 demandes d'asile
c'est une hausse de 29% par rapport à
Londres à l'an dernier à 56000 personnes
ont reçu une protection non globalement
que ça soit dans les pays non de l'Union
européenne ou seulement en France et
bien il y a 60% de déboutés du droit
d'asile quels sont les droits de
demandeurs d'asile et bien d'abord en
France tout demandeur d'asile a le droit
à un logement un hébergement il est
autorisé à travailler mais seulement à
partir de six mois après le dépôt de sa
demande d'asile dans ces 6 premiers mois
il bénéficie du aide financière
notamment de la location de demandeurs
d'asile cette personne a également accès
aux soins et ses enfants ont le droit à
une scolarisation Valérie Boyer est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui le droit d'asile est
dévoyé dans notre pays en fait tout à
l'heure vous posez la question est-ce
qu'il faut revoir le droit d'asile le
droit d'asile est revu de lui-même
puisque c'est plus qu'un dévoiement
c'est une filière d'immigration
et c'est particulièrement grave parce
que c'est la façon dont on gère le droit
d'asile parce que quatre plus de 90% des
personnes déboutées du droit d'asile ne
sont pas reconduites à la frontière donc
on est vraiment dans une filière absolue
et je trouve ça très grave à la fois
pour les personnes qui rendent de façon
régulière mais aussi pour tous les
combattants de la liberté qui ont besoin
de ce droit d'asile que personne ne veut
remettre en cause en revanche c'est le
dévoiement du droit d'asile qui remet en
cause ce droit d'asile aujourd'hui parce
que c'est une souffrance pour tout le
monde et puis qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
enfin qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire est-ce
que le droit d'asile c'est mettre des
gens dans des bidonvilles portent de la
chapelle est-ce que le droit d'asile
c'est relocalisé ces personnes dont on
sait qu'elles vont être déboutées ce qui
est absolument scandaleux moi j'ai
appris hier que par exemple en aurait 50
personnes qui seraient relocalisées à
Marseille par semaine pour les Jeux
Olympiques ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on déplace les gens comme des
pions
une personne est un pion qu'on la met à
un endroit où on n'est pas en capacité
de les accueillir donc c'est absolument
scandaleux je pense que il est temps de
revenir à des pratiques
dignes et humaine parce qu'on ne peut
pas faire supporter ça aux Français et
on ne peut pas faire supporter ça à ces
personnes leur faire miroiter l'Eldorado
d'autant que c'est procédures coûte
extrêmement cher donc moi je le redis si
sur ce plateau vous le savez Éric Ciotti
Bruno et Olivier Marleix ont tendu la
main au gouvernement alors c'est pas une
c'est une main ferme qu'ils veulent
c'est pas une mamole avec des soi-disant
mesures et du en même temps et je
rappelle que le pacte d'immigrations
n'a pas rencontré un accord au sein de
l'Union européenne puisque vous savez
qu'on on taxe de 20.000 euros un pays
qui refuserait des migrants
moi je pose la question de façon globale
pourquoi et en quoi
les pays de l'Union européenne qui sont
déjà extrêmement généreux dans leur
accueil dans leur mesure sociale etc
doivent être victimes de ces trafiquants
d'être humain à cette échelle
industrielle aujourd'hui jusqu'à quand
ça va durer cette sinistre a fait je
vais laisser le xn au revoir
d'immigration aujourd'hui le droit sur
la partie européenne parce que il faut
pas tout confondre c'est 20000 euros par
personne par an qui seraient
effectivement refusé dans la répartition
européenne et c'est par exemple pendant
si je peux juste terminer la proposition
qui est républicains font depuis
toujours ce sont des quotas des quotas
de répartition européen avec un quota
qui serait chiffré par le Parlement
européen par le Parlement européen
chaque année et aujourd'hui la barre a
été fixée à 120 000 entrées répartie
dans les 27 pays européens je termine
simplement ça n'a pas été refusé c'est
la Hongrie et la Pologne qui n'ont qui
ont voté contre mais c'était une
majorité
modifier et l'ensemble des pays ont
obtenu la majorité pour faire avancer ce
texte ensuite c'est au président de la
République et au chef d'État et du
gouvernement au Conseil européen de se
saisir de la question et de ses
propositions sur les propositions au
niveau national moi je ne crois pas
qu'il faille sortir des traités
européens je crois que ce serait l'exact
inverse de ce qu'il faudrait faire
regarder la Grande-Bretagne la
Grande-Bretagne est sortie de l'Union
européenne a durcit sa politique
migratoire il n'y a jamais eu autant de
migrants sur le sol britannique que dans
l'année 2022 600 000 entrées contre 300
000 avant le brexit l'Europe protège en
sortir et c'est ce que propose les
républicains
on propose en aucun cas
européens ça revient à dire Madame Boyer
que c'est un frexit migratoire qui ne
dit pas son nom c'est de n'a rien à voir
madame vous voyez regardez la
Grande-Bretagne il n'y a jamais eu
autant d'entrer sur le territoire
britannique de migrants qu'en 2022 600
000 entrées illégales pourtant le
Premier ministre conservateur on a fait
sa priorité tout comme Madame en Italie
qui dit avec moi il n'y aura plus
d'immigration illégale il n'y a jamais
eu autant d'immigration en Italie que
l'année 2022 bref qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire il faut s'entendre à 27 non mais
c'est pas des moulinets c'est des
propositions concrètes et des exemples
non concrets que sortir des traités
sortir de l'Europe durcir le thon ça ne
marche pas il faut s'entendre à 27
écoutez je m'inscris en faute dans cette
espèce de Gloubi global d'éléments de
langage
madame Boyer en Grande-Bretagne
proposent et il faut croire que cette
proposition
a marqué puisque tous les partis
politiques après nous avoir dit que
c'était pas possible du général de
Gaulle propose de sortir des traités
européens forcément ça marque madame
Boyer
on propose de redonner et ça je vois pas
en quoi c'est un constitutionnel où ça
nous permettrait de redonner la parole
aux Français est-ce que faire un
référendum sur l'IMM est-ce que faire un
référendum sur l'immigration c'est
anticonstitutionnel un référendum
sentier constitutionnel est-ce qu'on
peut pas demander aux Français
est-ce qu'on peut modifier on ne peut
pas demander aux Français ça marche pas
l'article sur le référendum sur
l'immigration écoutez moi j'en ai assez
de tous cette espèce de soupe que vous
nous servez en permanence
ce ne sont pas des incantations c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement précis je ne
pense pas que Olivier Marleix Éric ceci
Bruno retaillod ce soit de dangereux
frexitaires
pourtant c'est ce qu'il propose il
propose de redonner la parole aux
Français pour que les Français enfin
puissent retrouver la maîtrise de leur
destin ça me semble pas quelque chose
d'inconstitutionnel ou d'anti-repaire au
contraire je pense que c'est sauver
l'Europe que de redonner la parole au
peuple parce que les Européens on
débarrasser tous les pays sont
confrontés à ce chaos migratoire qui est
aggravé par des décisions qui sont
prises au sein de l'Union européenne moi
ce que je vous souhaiterais aujourd'hui
c'est que on soit bien clair sur ce qui
se passe on n'a jamais accueilli autant
d'étrangers en situation régulière ou
irrégulière le droit d'asile est dévoyé
c'est à dire que nos beaux principes
d'accueil d'accueillir les combattants
de la liberté sont dévoyés par des
personnes qui n'ont rien à faire qui
savent parfaitement comment maîtriser
nos procédures pour pouvoir les
contourner donc moi je souhaite
préserver le droit d'asile je souhaite
préserver la souveraineté de françaises
enfin je souhaite la retrouver et je
souhaite aussi rester dans l'Union
européenne moi aussi j'aime l'Europe
mais je n'aime pas l'Europe qui souhaite
répartir les migrants enfin franchement
en ce moment ce que ce qu'on propose aux
Français c'est de répartir des personnes
qui sont rentrées illégalement qui ont
fait en sorte de convoquer une procédure
illégale qui sont déboutés et qu'on va
replacer dans
toute la France c'est ça les souffrances
que vous voulez infliger aux Français et
aux migrants c'est juste pas possible
soyez courageux prenons écoutez
reprenons votre expérience
[Musique]
qui la situation aujourd'hui nous
souhaitons faire en sorte
majorité à l'époque donc effectivement
il faut résoudre quelque chose il y a un
défi migratoires il y a une pression
migratoire
mis en place par les gouvernements
successifs vous avez fait partie de ces
gouvernements successifs en 2018 j'étais
député et j'ai assisté et j'ai participé
à toute la loi colon qui n'a fait
qu'aggraver qu'aggravé la situation pour
laquelle nous nous retrouvons l'avenir
et on peut s'entendre sur des
propositions où on reste dans des
incantations et des discours réglés qui
marchent pas avez-vous entendu
mais j'en ai pas profité pour prendre la
parole j'étais tout seul simplement on
doit s'entendre on doit s'entendre au
niveau national avec des parties de
gouvernement et je pense que les
républicains sont un parti de
gouvernement à partir du moment où il ne
propose pas comme solution de sortir des
traités européens et de faire comme la
Pologne et la Hongrie de Victor Hormann
d'ailleurs ça marche pas et à la fin ils
reviennent toujours à Bruxelles demandez
de l'argent pour qu'on les aide à
répartir justement ces migrants on l'a
vu pendant la crise ukrainienne ou la
Pologne a particulièrement été digne
dans la gestion de cette crise ensuite
il faut s'entendre à 27 quand le pacte
immigration propose des centres de
transit aux frontières extérieures de
l'Union européenne pour traiter
justement les demandes d'asile sur les
pays d'accueil et ensuite de
raccompagner ceux qui ne sont pas
bénéficiaires du droit d'asile dans des
pays d'accueil tiers sur c'est une
proposition que nous pouvons je suis sûr
évaluer discuter et négocier au niveau
européen par ailleurs le président de la
République il faut gérer les demandes
d'asile en dehors des fonds nationales
sur les pays d'accueil sur les pays
d'entrée les pays du premier entrée
l'Italie la Grèce faire des centres de
transit qui sont qui sont qui sont en
clair des centres ou une frontière qui
s'applique automatiquement et où les
demandes d'asile seraient traitées ceux
qui ont son Béné
un centre de demande d'asile je suis pas
sûr que vous ayez beaucoup de monde de
au guichet et je suis pas sûr que ça
soit très facile et efficace de faire
l'être humain qui s'en charge
aujourd'hui
quand ces personnes arrivent en Italie
vous mettez un centre de transit vous
mettez un centre du transit vous
examinez les demandes d'asile les gens
doivent repartir dans un pays d'accueil
de un pays tiers sur vous allez pas les
renvoyer là où il y a la guerre vous
pouvez le renvoyer dans des pays que
nous avons collectivement jugé comme sur
ça c'est une proposition qui a été
adoptée y compris par votre famille
politique au Parlement européen j'ai
inventé rien le PPE a voté cette
résolution et cette disposition avec
réunion de Stéphane séjourner qui
représente la majorité présidentielle au
Parlement européen et avec les
socialistes la preuve que l'on peut
s'entendre sur des résolutions en
matière d'immigration dès qu'on sort des
vieilles lunes des incantations et des
fausses en mètres ce sont des nouvelles
alors si vous pouvez la réponse et après
on va faire un point sur ce que vous
proposez chacun bah écoutez je pense que
les propositions des républicains sont
claires et nets c'est deux lois une qui
une loi une loi ordinaire donc on
connaît parfaitement les contours
puisque elle reprend des propositions
qui ont toutes été refusé par lrem et
Renaissance aujourd'hui je rappelle que
Édouard Philippe qui fait partie de la
majorité
je sais pas il a je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé a dit qu'il fallait revenir
sur les traités de 68 avec l'Algérie je
rappelle qu'il a refusé de façon
extrêmement méprisante lorsque nous
l'avions proposé effectivement en 2018
et qu'aujourd'hui et bien nous nous
avons
exactement nous avons déposé au Sénat
une résolution pour revenir sur ces
traités j'espère que vous la voterez
enfin vos collègues qui siègent à
l'Assemblée nationale la voteront ça
c'est la première chose et deuxièmement
nous ne proposons a rien de la
constitutionnel arrêtons arrêtons nous
proposons simplement est-ce que comment
vous pouvez considérer qu'être que c'est
être inconstitutionnel de demander aux
Français ce qu'ils veulent faire
un moment donné il fallait gagner les
élections c'est pas vous de décider si
on doit mettre en place un référendum ou
non je rappelle que votre programme
donc un moment donné vous pouvez nous
dire faites un référendum il faut à ce
moment-là gagner les élections donc si
on dit que le référendum est une
préventive du président de la République
c'est au président de la République
c'est le président de la République qui
doit décider au moins de faire la
référendum et je vous rappelle
simplement
parti politique il est député il est pas
président de la République et encore une
fois en 2022 les républicains ont fait 4
% aux élections présidentielles donc un
moment donné il va falloir s'entendre
aussi avec la majorité qui gouverne le
président de la République qui préside
et c'est à lui que revient la décision
ou non de faire un référendum il sait
déjà exprimé sur le sujet il
constitutionnelle ce référendum sur
l'immigration ce n'est pas possible vous
pouvez raconter ce que vous voulez aux
Français ce n'est pas possible de faire
un référendum sur l'immigration
l'article 11 ne prévoit pas ce genre de
question c'est la raison pour
laquelle aux Français de le modifier
un homme de modification de constitution
à un moment donné
soit on accepte la situation de chaos
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons qui est
quand même je le rappelle une souffrance
pour tout le monde pour les Français
comme pour ceux à qui on fait croire
qu'il y a un eldorado et qui se retrouve
échoué sur le périphérique nous faisons
des proposition concrète et après il
faut faire des fausses promesses les
propositions on peut enfin arrêter le
même temps le référendum n'est pas une
pause promesse le référendum le
référendum est une tous les
constitutionnalistes que l'on écrit
l'article 11 est-ce que
[Musique]
quand même que dans ce pays que dans ce
pays c'est c'est exactement ce que nous
Marine Le Pen les arguments les
arguments totalement la démocratie
d'opinion
ça ne change pas la situation sur toi
moi j'aimerais bien pouvoir continuer
une phrase sans être intelligent plus
poser une question donc est-ce que le
risque parce que vous n'avez pas l'air
de pouvoir vous entendre c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas de texte et que vous soyez tous
les deux perdants et les républicains et
la majorité présidentielle c'est
évidemment tout ce qu'on veut éviter
de vrais propositions de réels promesses
et de vrais dispositifs quand on dit
référendum sur l'immigration on a beau
répéter les constitutionnalistes ont
beau répéter que l'article 11 n'est pas
le bon cadre ça ne marche pas c'est faux
parce que des constituent sanalistes
disent le l'inverse et à un moment donné
je ne vois pas franchement je suis je
suis sidéré de constater que en France
proposait un référendum c'est
anticonstitutionnel enfin on est en
marche sur la question
ça marche sur la tête il faut nous avons
des constitutionnalistes qui ont dit
l'inverse c'est faux vous pensez vous
pensez vraiment que Bruno Retailleau
Gérard
larcherelles
je rêve est-ce que du coup à ne pas
trouver d'accord vous ne risquez pas
justement de faire le jeu du
rassemblement national nous nous avons
nous avons nous avons proposé des choses
extrêmement concrètes je rappelle que en
début d'année le gouvernement a proposé
de procéder à des régularisations
massives de personnes qui sont rentrées
illégalement sur notre territoire ou qui
s'y maintiennent illégalement ce que
nous avons refusé parce que nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui lutter contre le
communautarisme faire en sorte que le
principe d'assimilation s'applique
vraiment ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et nous voulons éloigner les
personnes qui représentent une menace
pour notre pays et nous souhaitons que
des demandes d'asile se passe à
l'étranger et nous ne voulons pas que
l'on puisse régulariser des personnes
qui sont entrées illégalement sur notre
sol ou qui s'y maintiennent illégalement
franchement c'est quand même redonner la
maîtrise aux Français maintenant que le
gouvernement ne prennent pas ces
responsabilités c'est son choix il a
besoin des républicains pour trouver une
majorité nous lui proposons ce texte et
bien la balle est dans son camp mais
l'immobilisme il est pas chez nous il
est chez vous puisque c'est vous qui
avez gagné les élections à leur proposer
quelque chose non mais nous proposons
non mais vous proposez proposer quelque
chose
qui permettent aux Français qui
permettent aux Français de retrouver la
maîtrise de leur dessin parce que depuis
un dernier mot parce qu'il aura 30
secondes
ni autant d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière prendre le contrôle
reprendre le destin redonner c'est
exactement les slogans du brexit c'est
exactement ce que proclamait Boris
Johnson au moment de sa prise de poids
et ça s'accompagne de quoi d'un
référendum tiens donc et d'une sortie
des traités européens je ne parle pas je
parle de la France madame et je pouvais
prendre l'exemple danois je prends
l'exemple du brexit
c'est la réalité et c'est le titre de
séjour accordé effectivement à des
travailleurs qui sont installés en
France depuis 3 ans et qui bossent très
dur et le plus le plus souvent dans des
métiers peu qualifiés et très exposés
la réalité et vous êtes contre
le débat autour de ce texte aujourd'hui
Madame nous avons 4 millions de
personnes qui sont au RSA dont 40% qui
n'ont pas le a d'activité dont
l'activité n'est pas mise en oeuvre je
prends un débat le on peut avoir ce type
de débat et quand on en fera
il faut qu'on rapidement ce qu'elle a
une de nos quotidiens régionaux avec
Alex
[Musique]
une revue de presse régionale très
internationale aujourd'hui on commence
par là à mort de Sylvie Berlusconi et
oui beaucoup de une sur la mort de cette
figure de la politique italienne a duo
Silvio titre Nice-Matin de la réussite à
la décadence estime la Provence qui
résume la vie de celui qui a été un
homme d'État un homme d'affaires un
homme de foot puisqu'il a réussi avec le
club du Milan AC et aussi un homme de
phrases qui leur a vécu 1000 vies titre
le journal Les Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace quelle l'Italie s'emberlusconi
se demande le Télégramme tellement il a
marqué l'histoire récente de son pays il
avait un lien fort également avec la
France puisqu'on le rappelle il a lancé
une chaîne de télé la 5 dans les années
80 une aventure qui s'est soldée par un
échec alors demain seront organisés des
furets de mirails d'État au domo 2000
ans le gouvernement de Georgia Meloni a
proclamé une journée de deuil national
pour demain et puis direction l'Ukraine
ou la contre-offensive ukrainienne est
enfin lancée c'est elle a une de la
Dépêche du Midi qui est va annoncé la
reconquête de quelques villages du
don-basse des combats sont menés sur
plusieurs fronts notamment dans le sud
dans la région de zapporija Emmanuel
Macron estime que cette contre-offensive
va durer plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois on parle de la notion de
censure aussi dans la presse régionale
tic-tac titre La Marseillaise le
gouvernement borne tient bon mais
jusqu'à quand la motion de censure
déposée à l'Assemblée nationale par la
nups hier n'a pas été adoptée il
manquait 50 voix la gauche a dénoncé à
la dérive autoritaire du gouvernement
qui s'est opposé à un vote sur
l'abrogation de la retraite à 64 ans il
reste maintenant un mois à Isabelle
borne pour réussir les 100 jours
d'apaisement du pays l'objectif fixé par
le président de la République il fera
les comptes le 14 juillet merci beaucoup
de plateforme public sénat.fr à 18h vous
avez rendez-vous avec Thomas Hugues et
nous on se retrouve demain
[Musique]